LARRY P. ARNN: Our
speaker is Thomas Connor.
He's known around here as "Doc."
He holds degrees
from Elizabethtown
in North Carolina, Chapel Hill.
He is our most decorated
professor, this Professor
of the Year that I announced.
He's won that four times.
Nobody else has.
Why?
Sometimes I think
he's like a grandpa
to them, and
sometimes like a dad.
They flock to his
classes on the great wars
and on modern European history.
They travel with him every year.
maybe not this year--
probably couldn't go this year.
He goes to battlefields,
and he walks them,
and he knows the story.
And he takes them to cemeteries.
I've been on one
of these things.
And you go to the
American and the British--
those are the two best.
He might like the
British a little better.
I don't know, but
they're very good.
And he's a critic of
these things, right?
And the French and
the German, and he
has great reverence
for all of them.
You walk around, and you
honor even the enemies
of the United States, who are
dead, who gave their lives.
And then he can comment on the
differences of tone and shade,
which represent the
differences in the nation.
From this experience,
he has written
the authoritative history of the
United States Battle Monuments
Commission.
And it is a solemn and
beautiful book to read.
Senior class officers
wanted him because they
wanted this commencement,
the threatened
one, the interrupted one, to
be ours, just us family here.
Welcome, Thomas Connor.
[APPLAUSE]
THOMAS CONNER:
Thank you, Dr. Arnn.
This is really a beautiful scene
and a beautiful moment as well.
I think that heavenly
breeze is going to be
our salvation from the heat.
And it would probably also add
10 or 15 yards to a Joe Phillip
field goal attempt.
President Arnn, Chairman
Sajak, Chairman Brodbeck,
Class President Buchmann,
trustees, staff,
and faculty colleagues,
parents, friends, and guests
of the college, and,
most especially,
members of the
graduating class of 2020,
from both the undergraduate
college in the Graduate
School of Statesmanship,
this is the thrill
of a lifetime for me.
And a thrill at my age can
be a very dangerous thing.
[CHUCKLES]
Nevertheless, I'm grateful
to the president, the class
officers, and many others
for the invitation to speak.
And I'm especially
honored and humbled
for knowing that every one of
the three dozen commencement
speaker's who have played this
part during my service here
have surpassed me by wide
margins in either fame,
fortune, or both,
from Malcolm Forbes
and Russell Kirk in the
1980s, to Vice President Pence
and General Neller
most recently.
But my good fortune has
exceeded theirs and at least
one respect.
None of them has known
the incomparable joy
of spending their careers here
in the beautiful company of so
many that I have
shared for so long.
Henry VIII was supposed to have
promised each of his wives,
don't worry, I'll only
keep you for a while.
I'll only keep you for a while.
Because I make you
the same promise,
I don't want to say another
word without doing two things.
One is to extend my most
heartfelt congratulations
to each one of the graduates on
your outstanding achievement.
And because the mood
in the wider society
is so unhinged right now,
I want to urge each of you
in the strongest terms
never to let anyone,
whether to your face or in
the media, cast aspersions
on the accomplishment we
celebrate today on the grounds
that you have been
unfairly privileged.
There is nothing
inherently illegitimate.
[APPLAUSE]
There is nothing inherently
illegitimate or abusive
to others about the individual
abilities you have cultivated
and refined, or the
hard work you've put in,
or the supportive home
environment your families have
worked so hard to
provide in order
to prepare you for the
rigors of higher education.
The second thing I want
to do is to assure you
that the only thing
ending today--
there's a lot beginning.
But the only thing ending is
your daily presence on campus.
You will always remain
part of and have
an active claim
upon the fellowship
and the friendship
of this college.
It's important that
you never forget that.
We certainly find
ourselves in the midst
of a very tough stretch.
For personal family reasons
and for far broader ones,
I would love to turn the
clock back to New Year's day
and give 2020 a second
chance or, for that matter,
as many chances as it might
take to produce something closer
to what our fondest hopes
imagined for the past five
months when the year began.
Yet, amidst all the
disruptions, disappointments,
and dangers of
the recent months,
one reality looms large.
Although we are in the
midst of a pandemic;
although domestic
peace has broken down,
especially in the streets
of our great cities;
although forces bent on
rewriting or repudiating
our history and tearing
down our livelihoods
and system of government
are running rampant;
although the promising
economy of February
has become the depressed economy
of March and April and beyond;
although some of you
may have forfeited
or had to defer
job opportunities
amidst the economic
chaos; although weddings
had to be postponed or modified;
although Hillsdale College had
to embrace universal online
instruction for a distressingly
long period of time; and
although the class of 2020
has had to make up,
in a single weekend,
for what should have been
closer to two full months
of celebratory activities--
and you've done an admirable
job of that, I might add--
the world has not
really changed.
I was drawn to this theme
for tonight's address
by recollections from the
last great national shock
that we all lived
through 9/11/2001.
Many commentators
on that occasion
claimed that the attacks
in New York and Washington
had quote, "changed the world."
But I remember thinking,
even at that time,
that that wasn't true.
The world had not changed when
the Twin Towers and those four
planes came crashing down.
Rather, what had changed was
our understanding of the world.
We were forced, perhaps
some for the first time,
to realize that our
country was not completely
secure from murderous
attacks from abroad
and that there was such a
thing as evil in the world.
We have been re-reminded
of those facts
continually in the current year.
If it's not international
terrorists, but rather
tiny microbes trying
to kill us today,
we still confront
lethal dangers.
And if the evil
stalking us appears
to be more homegrown in
2020 than the imported
violence of 2001, nobody
ever said that evil
can't come in many guises.
All of these hard
realities and many others
too confirm what has been true
since the dawn of humankind.
The world is fallen, filled
with danger, fraught with risk,
forever flawed.
It is, in fact, a battleground
between good and evil.
The battle won't end
until God's appointed time
and in accordance
with his eternal plan.
This world, moreover,
is not all there is.
Nor, in the scheme of eternity,
is it our final destination.
The whole of the Judeo-Christian
tradition affirms these things.
And it is not within
human capacity
fundamentally to change them.
Those who claim to have
a prescription for making
the world a perfect
place, by the way,
are the most dangerous
radicals of yesterday, today,
and tomorrow, all
richly deserving a place
on the ash heap of history.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, if the cosmic
story can sound grim
and the worldly reality
is beset with troubles,
both are far from hopeless.
There is plenty of goodness,
truth, and beauty in the world.
And we know, as people of faith,
that God has willed all three
to triumph in the end.
During the time that
we are given here,
it is our highest calling to
bear witness to these things
and to fight for them
with every breath.
Martin Luther put it this
way in his powerful hymn,
"A Mighty Fortress is Our God."
"And though this world
with devils filled
should threaten to
undo us, we shall not
fear for God has willed his
truth to triumph through us."
If it's important
for the graduates
not to succumb to
unrealistic hopes
as you begin the next
chapters of your life,
it is equally important
for you to gird yourselves
for what you can
and must contribute
to the right side
of the battle that
continues to define the nature
of the world and our purpose
in it.
In this commencement
season, it is well
to remember that yours is
certainly not the first class
at Hillsdale College to
graduate into an unusually
turbulent and threatening world.
Imagine what any
of the graduating
classes during the
early 1860s must
have thought as they observed
the realities of the Civil War
and weighed how
they should steer
their lives through that
great national crisis.
For the bulk of them, the
most immediate question
was how they could be useful in
the fight to abolish slavery.
Imagine what the graduating
classes of 1917 and 1918
and 1941 through 1945
must have thought
as they braced themselves for
whatever part they would play
in the two great World Wars,
where human freedom and right
and decency also
hung in the balance.
Imagine what the graduates
of a succession of classes
during the 1930s
must have thought,
as the worst economic
downturn in the nation's
history challenged and
restricted their options.
It is common knowledge around
here how Hillsdale graduates,
during the most famous
of our national crises,
rose to the challenges
of their times.
And it's no accident
that they did.
You must be no different.
Our hope and confidence are
that you will be no different.
Six of you have already chosen
and qualified for service
as officers in the United
States Marine Corps.
[APPLAUSE]
Many of you will
pursue other kinds
of military and public
service, further educational
opportunities,
teaching careers, jobs
in business and government, or
full-time roles in the home.
As we sit here, I
suspect that some of you
are unsure and perhaps,
anxious about what
you will be doing after this
milestone moment in your lives.
Well, take it from
someone who looks back
with sheer wonder
at how the nearly
50 years since his own college
graduation actually turned out.
You can't script a life.
It would take me
too long to recount
all of the unforeseen
and unforeseeable twists
and turns in my own career,
all the lucky breaks,
all the help I received
from mentors, colleagues,
and friends, all the kicks
in the teeth along the way.
None of us doubts
that each of you
will make your own
positive mark on the world.
God wants you to, and the
republic needs you to.
The simplest advice
I can give you
is always to be at your best.
Learn what you can from every
experience, good and bad.
Keep from doing and saying
foolish or idiotic things
on social media.
Devote yourselves
to the right things.
Pray without ceasing.
Be patient, and never give up.
The 15th day of next month
will mark the 75th anniversary
of the end of World War II.
Japan, the last of our
enemies still standing,
surrendered on August
15, 1945, VJ Day.
The end of history's
most murderous war
stands as the greatest
triumph of what
has been dubbed "the
greatest generation"
of our own national story.
It's important to make
clear, in any case,
that we don't remember so fondly
and proudly the men and women
of the World War II era
as the greatest generation
because they rid
the world of evil,
because they didn't,
and they couldn't.
We give them special
honor because they
did destroy the evils
that most directly
and urgently threatened their
most valuable principles
and the nation that they loved.
They did what their
country required of them
without complaining
and without flinching.
They won the battles that were
before them with God's help,
just as President Roosevelt
vowed they would do.
Once they had vindicated
the national cause
and helped to restore
tens of millions of people
all over the world to a life
of freedom and self-government,
they played the role of
citizen with the same selfless
dedication and humility as they
had played the role of soldier.
This is why we celebrate
them and are made poorer
as they pass into eternity.
God forbid that we
should ever forget them.
You need to be like them.
I submit to you that our country
thirsts for a new greatest
generation right now.
[APPLAUSE]
History has shown
before the threats
we face from abroad
and from within
and from a virus that
knows no borders.
Today's equivalent of
the Manhattan Project
may be Operation Warp Speed--
the race to come up with a
vaccine for the pandemic.
Familiar suspects continue to
threaten us from abroad as they
always have and always will.
The 21st century
Vandals and Huns
imperiling us from
within actually
speak English, in many cases,
college-educated English,
sometimes Ivy League English.
But the stakes could hardly
be higher if they screamed
at us in a foreign tongue.
The measure of greatness of any
generation of our countrymen
has always been how
well they stood up
to the threats
against their freedom
and the security of
their way of life.
What's distinctive
about today's dangers,
the ones you will have to
take the lead in overcoming,
is how insidious they are.
Recent polls and recent actions
are extremely troubling.
Within your generation,
a recent poll
claimed 18- to
35-year-olds, that is,
only a minority, 35% to
40% assigned importance
to such vital elements as
religion or patriotism.
Within the 55 and
older age group,
2/3 claimed that
religion was important,
and 80% claimed that
patriotism was important.
In the midst of the
urban disturbances
since the end of May, mostly
youthful crowds have burned
and desecrating
churches and the flag,
defaced some of our most
revered national monuments,
and chanted that America
has never been great.
Mount Rushmore, the
national anthem,
and the very idea
of Independence Day
have been disparaged
in the media.
A democratic
congresswoman insists
that the entire economic and
political system of the United
States needs to be torn
down in order to allow
for true fairness and equality.
What is so alarming
about this situation
is the compelling ignorance,
absence of sound discernment,
and lack of
historical perspective
on the part of those
who claim to show
the nation the path
to positive change,
all manifesting themselves
against the backdrop of such
a precipitous decline in
religious belief and love
of country.
As the rising generation of
active citizens and leaders,
your ability to resist
this onslaught of darkness
and to preserve the republic
that is our common heritage
is going to be tested.
The quality of your response
will depend, in large part,
on what you know, the value
you attach to what you know,
and the strength of
your own character.
Permit me, as one who is
quite aware of what you know,
to highlight some of the
most important elements
of this storehouse of
truth that must guide
and sustain you through what
will surely be critically
challenging times ahead.
You know that every human life,
whatever the race or ethnicity,
age, or gender, born
or unborn, is precious
and deserves to be defended.
[APPLAUSE]
None should ever be privileged
or advocated over others.
We are all made equally in the
image of God, and that's that.
[APPLAUSE]
If all lives matter, you
know that livelihoods
matter as well.
You know that each of us bears
a duty to ourselves, to family,
and to society to be
as enterprising as
possible with our
God-given abilities
and with the skills and
talents we have developed
with the help of others.
You know that human beings are,
by nature, social creatures
and meant to live in community.
As the ancients and common
sense alike tell us,
the family is the foundation of
society and the body politic.
Thus, you know that,
as families break down,
so will society and politics.
You know--
[APPLAUSE]
you know that order is
the first need of all.
These are Russell Kirk's words.
Authority, whether
public or parental,
that cannot or will not keep
order within our various levels
of community is not
worthy of the name.
You also know that the
foundation of politics
in a republic is self-government
and that self-government begins
with self and that, when
individuals habitually
yield to irrational disorderly
or destructive impulses,
community is impossible.
You know that, just as it is
in the nature of human beings
to sin, nations
will do likewise.
But you also know that
the history of our country
has been an ongoing
quest in keeping
with our founding ideals
to correct and atone
for our national sins and make
the imperfections of our union
something closer to perfect.
On this day, when a genuine hero
of the Civil Rights movement,
John Lewis of
Georgia has died, it
behooves us all to
rededicate ourselves
to the continuing effort to
achieve true racial harmony.
[APPLAUSE]
You know, in all humility,
that the more you know
doesn't necessarily make
you wiser or even smarter.
Certainly, the endless
flood of data careening down
the information
highway seems more
to have multiplied
stupidity than reduced it.
You know the need for
good faith discourse
in the ongoing
competition of ideas.
Rioting, cancellation, and
the dictation of angry mobs
will never be
suitable substitutes
for the honest and
reasoned debate that
is supposed to be the glory
of democratic self-government.
[APPLAUSE]
You know further that more and
more distanced and remote ways
of communicating
with one another
and transacting
our affairs is not
a prescription for a
healthier, stronger society.
Most importantly, you
know that each one of us
is beloved of the
God who created us
and that this God
desires each one of us
to pursue fellowship with him,
to serve him as our first love
and allegiance, to trust him as
our ever-present help in need,
and to acknowledge him as
the unshakable foundation
of our being.
As we contemplate the
parts we each will
play in trying to set right as
much as we can in this world,
more words from Luther's
already cited hymn remind us
that we can accomplish no truly
good thing without God's help.
And these words
also offer sure hope
for how the great drama
we're all living will end.
Here's the verse.
"Did we in our own
strength confide,
our striving would be losing?
Were not the right man on our
side, the man of God's own
choosing?
Dost ask who that may be?
Christ Jesus it is he.
Lord Sabaoth, his name,
from age to age the same.
And he must win the battle."
If any of this preceding
litany has seemed self-evident
or so commonly understood,
especially within this circle,
as not to merit restating,
permit me to share with you
a thought recently expressed
in a source sadly that I cannot
recall, but which went
something like this.
In times of trial, it
is the responsibility
of every educated person
to belabor the obvious.
This reminds us of
the advice coaches
typically give to their teams
when the teams are struggling
or when they're coming up
on a particularly big game.
We've got to concentrate
on the fundamentals.
We've got to get the
fundamentals right.
Indeed, we do, perhaps
as never before.
So in closing, I challenge
the graduates and all of us
here to bring as much
as we possibly can
of humanity, society,
decency, and dutifulness
to past, present, and
future into our households,
our places of work, and all
levels of our communities.
Affirm the fundamentals.
Seek the good.
Be guided by the truth.
What God has revealed
to us in his word
and in the time-honored
wisdom of the ages.
Love the beautiful.
These have been the
foundational elements
of your education here.
Much of the world is
at odds with them.
Your strength will rejoice
in the challenge of defending
and promoting them.
May God bless us everyone to
the task he's given us to do.
May he always guide, protect,
and prosper the United States
and this honorable college.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]